greetings from podcast Ville its
February 12th [ __ ] Tuesday get ready
to rock [ __ ] the church is brought to
you by for hems calm let me ask you
something is that hairline slowly
starting to move backwards any bald
spots yet how will you feel a year from
now well it's not business as usual up
there I asked you do you want a ball
spot to pop up or do you want to do
something about it first that's why you
gotta go to four hems calm a
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men him connects
you with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss with
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair and if you go on a date
that little extra push so she could be
happy do me a favor right now go for my
family church that's for the church
family I want you to do me a favor go to
four hymns calm right now and get a
trial month of hymns for five hours
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details this will cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy not tonight
because uncle Joey's taking care you go
to four hymns calm slash Joey that's
four hymns FR r hims calm slash Joey for
five hours for your first month while
supplies last the church is also brought
to you by listen it's time for you to
get you a cool idea into a new website
you get to showcase your work either
blog or publish content that's what
happens when you're with Squarespace
okay me I love them you could sell
products and services of all kinds you
could promote your physical online
business and you can announce upcoming
events or special projects and more what
I want you to do is head to square pace
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch now right now
when you're ready when you know exactly
what you want to do use the offer code
Church to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com and to church
the podcast is also
do you buyout it for the best
supplements out there from alpha brain
to shrimp go to alikom and press in
church and get 10% off your first order
take this [ __ ] muley and happy
new agency how long have you been in New
York for like nine months ten months
no but this last one remonstrate three
three months senior 90 days awesome
right right
Gotham yeah [ __ ] those anymore I know
days are moving so fast that's so true
once you get out of high school days fly
and then once you hit 50 you know and
everything's downhill now you try once
you hit 50 it's downhill you did the
first 50 yeah yeah
every morning you gotta kiss the floor
and say thank you for giving me another
one and you know what's going downhill
but you try to keep it uphill not my
plastic surgery just by sleeping and
resting and drinking water and walk in
and you know the days of [ __ ] flying
but it's good to have you back I think
what you think about the thing called
the Sun oh you see the Sun today I got
here yesterday it was pouring rain I'm
like what is this [ __ ] yeah I was
ready for like just some Sun but today
it's just oh we've had some [ __ ]
serious right yeah like there was some
days that I looked out the window and
said I haven't seen rain like this is I
was a kid like heavy there was one one
day ten days ago maybe I could not
[ __ ] believe it it was poor people
were flipping people flipping people can
not handle the rain in Southern
California people they cannot handle a
ring they fold under questioning yeah
they just cannot handle at the street
people pulling off it's it's insane yeah
it's been raining but at least there's
no more drought and outside your
bathroom window with a stopwatch bother
you shower with some guys out there yeah
yeah yeah I remember the sunrise yeah
70s they had that neighbor they would
say like you had to shower with your
parents I was like that's creepy
yeah you shower with your parents we are
save water he loves being kids and they
had the
gasps gasps wars no not the gas wars
when they would put the flags up
I remember the odd and even twist yes
yeah leaving plates I go back let me
tell how old I was with a flag yeah the
flag was like you had to go to your
local DMV or something and get the color
green red or orange
the only time we could buy yes and if
you had green it was clear you had a
family and [ __ ] like that like if you
were single and lived by yourself
you were like an army they would only
let you guess gas once a week it's so
crazy think about that that was like
codes that's when the Ayatollah Khomeini
early 70s early 70s late 60s and just
come from Cuba and those you know those
orange cones that you see on the street
yeah the flags would be in their flags
will be placed in this when you drove by
you know was your day to get gas I just
remember odd and even place I'd even
play whatever you're the one your plate
ended over the six you were even if it
ended with a five your odd and that's
how you would get gas it'd be odd and
even days was that was it a lot more
expensive than they used to be no but
there wasn't gasps it wasn't gas
Wow now they would raise the price oh
yeah oh it's now it's a different
[ __ ] boy yeah I was New York how was
his last run in New York housing it's
great I respect and admire the [ __ ] out
of you just you know there was enough
spots here you don't have to come you
still laugh and you don't and you don't
do bad here but you just wanted more
action than your [ __ ] and where do you
go in Arctica the [ __ ] kinda [ __ ] up
and I mean New York is a different
common experience then LA it's so weird
yeah when you eliminate the TV and all
that [ __ ] you see more pure comedy I
think so you don't see people selling a
TV show up on stage you see the heart
and balls of stand-up as in LA people go
well my agent said to do material on the
kid because yeah I want to shoot one
CBS comes to see me they want to know
that my material is based on the
challenge you don't get none of that
it's so weird but it's the nuts and
bolts economy and some people can't
handle that like I went to New York an
early state of comedy where it was
basically designed to kick the [ __ ] out
every time you walked out of an open mic
with 20 other comedians it was just to
test you whether you would jump over the
bridge on the way back to Jersey and uh
you know is that yeah and it made me
move back to Colorado and siphon what
what did you get from this last
experience in New York what it did for
me was I just didn't want to get
comfortable like I'm an LA comic here
this is what it is I was like I need to
push myself and be in a different
dynamic writing-wise performing wise
different rooms everything and to be in
the Comedy Cellar was it was an honor
and also I learned so much these guys
are all there they're not [ __ ] around
the Comley cell is you crow will become
exactly that's the two beasts right
there Comedy Store Comedy Cellar and the
guys in there I was working I was
working on that TV show we're live on
Comedy Central
live at the cellar and what you do is
they give you topics each week and then
you write some jokes and then they would
shoot on Thursdays and Saturdays shoot
like 40 comics and either your jokes
made it or they didn't make it
none of mine made it but it didn't
matter because I was included on the
show which was like to me an honor to be
working in this establishment the cellar
and to be on this show so each day would
it would I'd get out of bed and start
writing about these topics so it taught
me how to do some kind of you know
topical weekly jokes I've never really
done that kind of writing where they go
here's the topics gas Wars you know
jay-z did this does this happen you get
like three you know type food poison and
then you gotta write on that and show up
and it was it was hard and it was great
and I loved it you know I found an old
picture yeah
you were just a chubby yeah just Phatak
40-something year old yeah I know what
we doing for work then at that point
selling motorcycles right here on the
corner
Yeah right ever at Van Nuys Van Nuys
Boulevard can we make the Liberty some
more that's a big money really big money
yeah cuz you're experienced or I'm I
because I think I was the only guy there
that liked motorcycles so everybody else
is just like employs where that's where
they worked and they were burnout so
when people came in they could tell I am
knew everything about the bikes I love
the bikes and they're big out here
because you can run even between traffic
and the weather yeah so they come in and
I and I knew everything about him and
other guys would be like I remember guys
would do this they would be sitting on
the couch like yeah this guy never buy
[ __ ] dude and they wouldn't get up and
then I would go up hey what's going on
in that day they would buy a bike and
they go walked up [ __ ] you know their
guys work in there I [ __ ] talk to him
for two years
he'd buy [ __ ] on the bikes we sell
Harley's just straight up on straight of
Horace and that's a tough sell tough
sale because it costs big money and what
happened was I was doing it making good
money and then that whole Fannie Mae and
everything hit where everybody's loans
tanked on their homes and people just
gave their bikes back and no one was
buying bikes so you went from making
let's say like 10 grand a month to 900 I
remember I got a check for $900 I go I
just worked a month for $900 because
it's Commission only and I was like what
am I gonna do yeah cuz I was just
blowing money thinking it was gonna
happen forever how little did you work
there three years three years tonight's
gig when you're selling and you're
making money people have no idea how
it's fun no yeah it really is to sell
something the value not like insurance
because they can't see it right that's a
very hard sale that's
you can't but when you sell something
that you believe I'm like I worked with
this company when I first got divorced I
thought wasn't the work with them
forever
it was putting basically an old-school
telemarketing scam but I like the
product yeah there's a cut to this [ __ ]
I guess when you work in doctor's office
everybody has to be trained in that
stuff I forget where they're when it
comes to mind there's a a guideline that
you have to work on them this is named
for a seesaw or something like that out
I figure what the [ __ ] it is and I would
call these doctors they paid me 15 an
hour and 35 every time they kept the
thing and I would work 30 hours and walk
out of there one I can't tell you how
much a week yeah it lasted for like
seven months and then they said they had
to move to Denver
they were moving to like the other side
and then run I'm like I can't
yeah I can I can tell you I'm gonna do
it I'll do it three times
I'll get coked up one night and that
this was perfect there was times I would
get coked up till 5:00 and still be
there at 9:00 yeah and what's that
[ __ ] guy I forget what it is let's
see so but OSHA OSHA oh sure they were
like every doctor's office OSHA
regulated yeah so I believed in it so I
would call these doctors it's tough to
get doctor on the phone oh yeah and say
listen get it look at it the scam was it
they didn't send it back in 30 days then
they had a pain at 2:49 yep you know how
many doctors sent [ __ ] back and it makes
you it really did qualify you
so when OSHA came in you upped the
standards and all that [ __ ] you know
when I sold cars it's funny their dad
was thinking about my wife and I were
talking about how quick it is nowadays
to get what's that word like Kevin
Spacey you know to get Louis seek aid oh
it's the word is to get accused like not
like just one day you're this big thing
in today's society mind just a raise
next day you're erased you know
and I was telling my wife it's kinda
like when you go to prison and your name
comes on the paper you get arrested it's
one thing when you're gonna rest in and
you know I sit for a pound of weebo and
you gotta rest
and your neighbors see the cops coming
to your house
yeah and then your name comes out in the
paper like page - no even the [ __ ]
mailman will drop the mail off weird to
you but you don't know that till it
happens like when I came out on bail
people's behavior towards me was [ __ ]
horrendous and it makes you you know it
makes you feel really bad yeah but there
was one guy that did not turn up there
was one guy that was like [ __ ] it so
what you kidnap somebody good for you
you [ __ ] up [ __ ] it was Jim wheel and
he's his kids on a motorcycle shop now
in like North Dakota he was originally
from Detroit but he was a big Bruce Lee
guy and I never forgot that guy like I
never forgot Jim Wynn there his son
listen to the podcast one day and hit me
up on Facebook and said when you said
his name and blew our mind and he was
one of the only guys and like he was
getting married like two weeks later
he's like he coming to the wedding and
people come up to me at the wedding just
looking at me and tearing the heads like
this it was that fast yeah yeah and the
point I was trying to make it suck it's
I enjoyed my salesman days when I sold
cars those days or you just you got
another salesman you talk to people and
they're like you give me a brochure yeah
and you have to tell like it's an art to
take somebody who's looking for a
brochure and go you here already
yeah when I got a brochure let stand for
a draw and you don't even you learn how
to control a person by not controlling
them like you learn how to cut words out
of your nothing you know then you go to
seminars and you learn that if you're
having a conversation with somebody and
you turn your back on somebody and start
walking seven or ten times they'll
follow you yeah yeah yeah like if you're
talking to something you turn your back
and start walking impulsively like in
whatever that word is they start
following yeah so that's the same thing
you have to do it
milk coming to go hi I'm here looking
for a car for my daughter and I got a
brochure for sure
you gotta learn how to say that yeah
without be like this guys are the
salesmen though they're just dicks oh I
just did I worked as this one guy he was
just they're just dicks of a [ __ ] all
bad so I got nobody taking all my
customers that's always that one taking
my customers oh you know you think you
never forget those things in your life I
know like that you did that was just
right the first month of the business I
sold 13 cars yeah I was the same way
like my first
maybe he'll know like six people were
going crazy I had many tech grab my
first week it was that her way I was off
running yeah like the first week I had
bought like shitty suits yeah I went to
this Men's Warehouse and bought like 500
miles worth - closed my mother-in-law
let me her credit card and I'd pay him
back $50 a week for 10 weeks and I'd
well like you know three suit jackets
four pair of pants two pairs of shoes
but that's like two checks I was [ __ ]
getting done up jack I was buying these
attorneys suits yeah yeah and I felt
like somebody for a change there felt
like somebody the drug addiction part
was killing me but the process like my
dick would get on I'd see how Salman
would treat people and I'd go out with a
handler and then I would just look at
people and tell him what I wouldn't tell
the sound but I'd watch him and let's
see how they [ __ ] up the whole thing
Oh totally got into a talking match it's
a lot like comedy too many words yes and
the sales not gonna happen I'm not gonna
happen too many words you say the wrong
word in there and they're like yeah you
know it's really wild it's got to be
it's in and also you have to love it
when they know that you of the bike or
the car they're on board but if you're
just kind of like yeah you know the
thing I always got them with they'd be
like these are kind of dangerous right
on my cab if you're a posse you're not a
[ __ ] right no I take it you know you
they don't want to look like a [ __ ] it
was unbelievable was the most popular
Harley the fat the fat boy used to be
huge fat boy what's that go for the fat
boy the fat boy right now grow 18,000
and what's the one you had Road King
that's 25 25 grand yeah Road King and
then there's one right above it called
the Road Glide or the ultra that's the
one with the big fairing and the music I
had that one for years rode that across
country and what's that go for do about
32 what do people usually put down
something like that you only got to put
down 10% but Harley for a while
if you got good credit would take zero
down zero zero and everybody will take
zero now you didn't notice it right yep
yep exactly at least motorcycles no they
don't lease and they never did that but
I got an interesting story for you I was
selling motorcycles and then I started
to work at the factory and I was making
some as we're gonna like four or five
days a week I go to one of a you know
doing comedy I had got past at the
factory and I was like working quite a
bit and then all the sudden they
switched Booker's or whatever and I
wasn't working at all and had to go back
to selling motorcycles so I had left the
job was full-on comedy and then had to
go back and when I went back I was
selling beamers and they had a thing
that was close no motorcycles BMW
motorcycles on Santa Monica Boulevard
and they had a thing called the 3z where
you could buy a bike ride it for about a
year or two and then trade it in it was
like oh nice I'm training him for a new
one just keep getting the newer model
with no mile restriction restriction at
all
which is what so I got on that people
are like you always got a new bike I was
like yeah man I just get one ride the
[ __ ] out of it and then get a new one
because I was riding it everywhere doing
comedy I was doing like 30,000 miles on
a bike unheard about BMW of what the
State Patrol yes yep no Highway Patrol
and
so that's a good bike fw beside one of
the best bikes ever made and what are
they how many bikes do they have like
compared to they got lightly 10/10
models really yeah they have seen a lot
of BMW bikes and I always wonder the
bottom you know I started off as a
motorcycle yeah I kinda seventies
Kawasaki yep
Suzuki that Honda now I had the mini
trail and then I moved right into
[ __ ] Kawasaki and Suzuki though
nothing made my dick harder to be honest
here than the Suzuki xla right that was
the bike that broke my [ __ ] spirit
yeah like that was the first time I had
done speeds that I had never done before
oh yeah like the 50 I bought it out
you're like listening go and Joe you're
50 you're a [ __ ] I know yeah yeah I was
11
as you know by the time I was 12 13 I
think I was 12 I got on the XL 80 yeah
birthday on the Honda Honda made a 75
yep I forget what that what Excel and
then I'll Kawasaki made in Excel my
friend
sold me on the [ __ ] decked out eighty
Suzuki and it was [ __ ] great
Yallah Suzuki had the RM DRM but I'm
talking 73 74 75 yeah then I got that
dirty Suzuki 125 yeah you know cuz what
we had was a group of guys that we all
like the same bikes but what we do is I
like the Suzuki you like the Kawasaki
get the Kawasaki I'll get the Suzuki you
get the [ __ ] Honda and would you
switch yeah like we would just switch go
get with I don't think we would get
higher then no yeah I would get hired I
never got high rode motorcycles I was
[ __ ] paranoid yeah just that little
switch that I had to make with there's
too many cars for me
yeah and I still remember doing three on
a bike I still three out of bike I
stomach Frankie bowels and all driving
me on the back holding on for dear life
yelling and his galloping Ilona Merton
sitting on the handlebars
haha three [ __ ] and be holding on
be alive going I'm gonna [ __ ] die
without a helmet on oh my god that was
really my explosion explosion but you
know my my break in comedy was that
first bit nuts to butts about riding my
buddy riding on the back he crashed and
I said get on I gotta take him to the
hospital he's like I'm not going nuts to
butts with you and it killed it for a
couple years people would be like nuts
to butts Oh everywhere I went I thought
I was gonna be the I thought that was
going to be the only bit I ever had I
remember talking to delay about it
I got dude did you eat your big big
closer how did you ever get so because
yeah you think you're never gonna get
something and then one day it just
happens it was so weird they're so like
my comedy was from motorcycles which is
pretty interesting though do they hire
anybody for motorcycles I would you have
to be a motorcycle enthusiast oh come on
oh can i tomorrow war now the BMW and go
yeah I've rode motorcycles I haven't
been on one at close to 40 years after
another motorcycle now I have not been
on a motorcycle close to 40 years Tim
don't worry while there was a time when
I could think straight like I had all
the brochures yeah I had all the
magazines you know my mom didn't really
know what was going on like I had
different helmets and different bikes
Hedlund [ __ ] yeah I don't want your mom
there now
I would save money I really had a 75 but
I had an 80 around the corner I'd [ __ ]
217 those garage his mother would pull
me aside and say does your mom know
about the bike in my garage mom this is
a patina don't worry about like you just
i loved all that [ __ ]
I still remember training and she didn't
catch it now and then one day she came
up from the laundry she's like when did
you get a bigger motorcycle like I was
already on that trip when I was 12 I was
making business moves left I don't even
know and they were playing catch up to
me like when did you get the bigger
motorcycle where'd you get the money
from
yeah you know I worked at the bar I did
the numbers for a few weeks you know
what she would just shake
like you're always up to no good I was a
helmet enthusiast
I loved helmets sure I [ __ ] loved
helmet so I'd be epic innocence I'm 11
guys I'd be at the Kawasaki plays
jerking off all day helmets and bicycles
there was a kawasaki place a mile from
my house when I was a kid and today it's
not there anymore but down the block is
a White Castle
could you imagine that White Castle have
been there when I was a kid Hall you
walk up to revenge Street you make a
left and right there it was round the
corner and we'd walk up there we'd ride
first
we'd ride till we couldn't ride anymore
and then go home take showers then we'd
walk up the hill and go to the car we
place and [ __ ] you know we were kids
yeah yeah yeah I wrote I wrote forever
man my first one was the you remember
the mini bikes with the Briggs &
Stratton Oh father engine [ __ ] yeah yeah
this kid dumb well did ya um well what
with the [ __ ] it screws on the bottom
you just said it was only four screws
holding that engine that's a frame I
remember this kid Dominic had a couple
and he sold me one with my paper out
money and it caught on fire
how much are these mics $8.00 are you
buying them in cash is a 12 year old huh
oh I bought the mini Bob which was your
like 50 bucks
that was your the minibike though the
Stratton okay Briggs and Stratton
ten or fifteen or singe in you pull the
thing the [ __ ] throttle with the
string would break a break stick right
open you have to jump off it guys you
have no idea but some people listen to
the podcast they remember they're old
enough
oh that shit's real - it's real and then
the string would break and you'd have to
take the [ __ ] cover off it ah and
rewrapping rewrap it oh and then [ __ ]
pull it I had I was very happy see like
I told you guys listen I just got my
life together when I was 44 before that
I just called a [ __ ] Ville I had these
bikes I disclosed [ __ ] oh yeah I was
[ __ ] you know everything's like Joey
no this
this listen to me I'm telling you I was
12 years ago when I was about 12 or 13
that was set like I had all the bikes I
made it all my friends like my other
friend had an India
oh yeah India you know we were all
shared Sam got a different experience I
was very content in my way but there was
this wild man in my neighborhood like he
just didn't shoot a baby though he shot
darts at you what was window yeah he had
three brothers that beat the [ __ ] out of
him and like four sisters don't check us
Avakian my everybody he was a muscle he
was a muscle the kid was just a muscle
since we were kids when we were kids one
time we put it down with a board he
would have you put your hand on the
board oh the dad went through it so much
he was like a serial what do you call us
like if you had a walk to school yeah he
would sit as an acquittal blow gun but
the blow dart has showed I'd say yes oh
they didn't know where the darts are
coming from like he shot like over 80
students and then would they realize it
was this [ __ ] lunatic oh this lunatic
had one of those briggs-stratton
yeah black beautiful finished the tires
the whole [ __ ] thing and one day he
just mentioned it to me cuz I'm looking
to get rid of it I don't know if I
trained them I cannot lie to you I
always tell the story I think I trained
it but I think I did paying 40 bucks now
that you seen yeah when I went and it
was Christmas Eve and I walked three
blocks to his house like oh yeah think I
wanna buy your bike then he goes you
know whatever and he goes before you
take it remember seats not into the
frame oh and I'm a bit taken at home
taking my time I have to go downstairs
and it's like you guys what the hell
these stairs the more the guy told you
in Charles Court to put away the camera
a little stairs
I rode those stairs in those days like I
would ride him on the bicycle and you
were trained to ride down whatever you
had and I still remember going down and
it was kind of snow and bringing it home
because my buddy borrowed that bike my
buddy heard me because I was trying to
fix the seat it was December 24th
10 o'clock at night and I'm out in front
of my house the garage door open
nobody's home my mama's got a bar yeah
my stepdads at the bar as long as I
closed the kitchen door the cold air
couldn't go into the house so I would be
out there with my jacket trying to screw
the see there and I'm rubbing it yeah
because he was a [ __ ] motorcycle nut
yep he was like a motorcycle bicycle in
fact in the book I was writing about of
the earth day that when you stole a
bicycle or you had to his we live into
him
two days later and you'd see that
bicycle in your life that's not the same
bike he's like yeah he would paint it
scrape off the VIN number put a new VIN
on it like he would make the badges
himself the kid was a genius yeah he's a
dentist today oh my calls he would
[ __ ] take the pop to thing off put a
new but then he there was a number in
the back of the bike that's how they
would determine if your bike was stolen
he would buff that off with his father's
[ __ ] the bristles here bristle yeah
yeah and one man I I knew he was a
morning he was like a bicycle
enthusiasts like if you had a bicycle he
got a ride at first his parents wouldn't
let him ride a motorcycle even know
everything about he knew a dizzy about
how to build a bicycle the inside to
that like as soon as I was outside
revving it took eight minutes to hear
all the storm windows going up yeah and
protect the Papa and he came down and
and I had him and the kid next to him
was a white dude with a crew-cut
he could fix anything so I did Mike I
got Michael Clements was his name he
would boil that [ __ ] out yeah
which meant that you gave it extra CCS
dudes out there like that
so if your bike was an eighty [ __ ]
pastor he would add bigger pistons he
would [ __ ] do the spark plugs for you
I get goose bumps yeah Michael Clements
would come over to my house and go you
know what the problem of your bike is
I'm he just started doing [ __ ] dropping
things changing oils Jackson air filters
things you've been still allowed could
be something like motorcycles that you
built your cell I guarantee there's a
couple of stolen
oh yeah listen when it's bikes out there
also I saw every year Sears would sell
that same mini bike at Sears like which
one the actual mini bike but that looked
like the one you
oh there it is the same thing but all
nice yeah I'll tell you what I almost
bought I almost bought a three-wheeler
those days they were flipping all right
yeah and they rip your foot off they
were flipping badly those yeah yeah yeah
they were flipping I was ready and
everybody was against it the three
wheelers everybody in those days we're
like don't do it this was like to me I
would fall on a two wheel I was like but
I'm - I was gonna say our three wheels I
would be ready to buy a three wheeler
you had somebody else made three
wheelers Honda Honda hot everything came
wheelers 80s ATC and they talked me out
of it's three wheel so you're riding and
then it would tilt and your mind would
say put your foot down but your back
tire would run over your foot oh I
didn't know that he would run over your
own foot so they made him illegal and
they went to four wheels
so there were three wheels for about
three four years my effect I was talking
about him on my podcast and I guess I
used to race those and he sent he sent
me some photos a him racing the three
Wailers you can you can YouTube it it's
wild it's still they still race the
three-way race the four wheeler it's not
the three
yeah the three wheelers what's it made a
million except when I was about 12 I was
gonna split a three wheeler yeah I can
be in a bunny man we're just gonna cut
in on one and on one but everybody was
like wait we're number one way you gonna
ride it the cops gonna pull you right
over you don't think too much heat too
much heat then let us ride it you know
and listen in those days it was just
like now if a cop sees you driving a
dirt bike he's got every right to pull
you over
yeah but if you're gonna tell him you're
going to that Park to ride it it's up to
him how cool you are
now they'll give you a ticket and tow
your bike instantly so back then let's
say the where I went to Road right now I
live in [ __ ] NoHo but let's say I
wanted to ride my bike in the summer a
Thousand Oaks
yeah Thousand Oaks correct we would have
to carry in a truck we didn't have a
truck no matter why nobody we would
nobody had a truck with a [ __ ]
carrier now we would ride those three
miles and
for the best yep and hope that a cop
would see us and chase us all the back
streets and yeah under the cop never
never never I never and I would go out
to route three you had to go onto Route
three for about a half a mile there was
a cut in the weeds and what you want in
there you would cut off you would cut
dirty Wow you go for 30 months yeah
that's before the Meadowlands and while
that industry was built on that just
know me there was a little shack there
was a little shack that sold hot dogs
this [ __ ] and that was our control spot
like we would go there park the bikes
eat and then go into the bushes and then
come out just the Sun was setting and
drink the soda there and eat the hot dog
there there was another one up the
corner from snappy nappies that was the
extent of my yes nappy nappy notice
nappy nappy keep your tummy happy go to
snappy nappies they even had a jingle
snappy nap it was tremendous the Shoei
Charlotte Highway it was on the side of
the highway up the block the gas station
I used to Rob Putnam fuel ah and then
you go went down another 50 20 30 yards
and that was that little Hut that had
hamburgers and stuff and you made a
right in there into the will you
disappear like the Batcave yeah one
minute
like if a cop was chasing you you just
beat would rear off it was thin enough
for a motorcycle but not the road wasn't
go for a car yeah
you're out of there like kids pass it
down like okay we'll show you how to get
to this place
I was showed those crazy dudes used to
take me down there in the walked it was
like a four mile walk to the trains and
if we wouldn't Rob trains on the walk
back then you break punks yeah those
sticks that you like yeah it's the
mosquitos oh yeah yeah and we need to
get 10 punks that's $10 because you saw
them let your fireworks yeah that's how
you look at your fireworks but you also
lit and when you're backyard but keep
the mosquitoes away if your family is
too cheap to buy off some of the ring
ring the road then you like the ring of
the bee those wouldn't come around but
if you let a punk the mosquitoes
wouldn't come around
so I knew my way around those swamps the
kids always tried to scam me I don't
know for sure they said that quicksand
down there anything's possible
sharing that quicksand I never stumbled
upon it yeah I think there were rumors
people would say we can't believe I'm in
this quicksand could see don't get
sucked into the mud you know and oh my
god how exciting like to get sucked into
the mud yes to pull you out [ __ ] I never
saw no quicksand that happened to me man
I was rafting my mom bought a raft for
my birthday and me and my buddy were
rafting in this river and the tide would
come in it would be full we didn't know
anything about tides and then it went
out and well a boat was just kind of
sitting there so I got out of it like
I'll just pull the block the boat out of
the river bed all the way down stuck in
there yeah there to call fire truck and
they put the long ladder out and then
pulled me out I was stuck in my it was
because once the water is out it's just
deep deep mud how old were you I was
like 12 11 this is outside the Sanford's
yeah so I was scared out of my ass like
I'm stuck I'm gonna die you know because
it was just mud all the way and if you
moved you sank no like like quicksand
oh man my buddy Comet izing was those it
was so hard with you I think it was like
11 and and we were right at the Trussell
and my buddy was in the boat still just
yelling help help for like a half hour
and then someone just happened to look
over and then they called the fire and
then I remember they were gonna try to
charge my mom the fire truck charged the
cup you know for helping me she's like
they're like yeah we're gonna have to
charge you for rescuers I get the [ __ ]
that really happened it's they're nuts
it just hit me just now I remembered
that yeah that's that's something a lot
of people are though that I love and I
still I still think about buying a
motorcycle get in the truck doing the
whole thing I asked it was like if I
move to a remote area yeah if I could
just get on a motorcycle do 35 miles put
a helmet
yeah I hate the [ __ ] jump Brandt
would jump of ramesses oh yeah
I was doing all that stuff you know her
and I went out to Riverside my buddy has
spikes in a truck and he goes I'll take
you guys out there so we're not to
Riverside - they got like five tracks in
this one place they got the beginner
track you bring your old bike though
yeah but he had a bunch of bikes let's
got Rob producer Ross Robinson he's a
famous producer so he took us out there
and we got on the baby track and just
rode all day and it was so much fun but
there was like six-year-olds flying over
us
yeah like completely over us like movie
old [ __ ] flying over us like Batman
[ __ ] but we had the timer right we're
out there all day we rode all day went
home went right to bed just done great
day especially when you guys robbing it
there's a lot of thought involved yeah
when you're a kid that you're very alert
you're switching gears you know that's
switching gears yeah and then when your
right foot and your left [ __ ] one
down four down four up yeah that [ __ ]
with you for a while when you have a kid
and this [ __ ] all the time I've been
doing this for 34 years now yeah you
drove cross-country that must be pretty
crazy it's great I did three times I
went to Sturgis
five times it's that's some of the best
times in my life just out there riding
with buddies to Sturgis that's so
incredible you can't even believe it
you're as long as you're not in the
frame of mind of like if we crash out
here we're dead you can't get that in
your head because you're out on these
roads there's no one for hours you know
like a car would come by anybody call if
you run out of gas there's no cell
signal because we fit crazy weird back
routes before I got left up I would ride
a bicycle all over Boulder I believed
you know the bicycle land I had a
Beachcomber
is that you can cruise a beach cruiser
yeah
right in the morning to swimming class
and sometimes I would ride at home to
work it it hurts and sometimes I would
write you know because you had a dress
nice and hurt you can't be riding a
[ __ ] bicycle yeah you get all sweaty
so I would ride in the mornings before I
swear I did the biathlon where you swim
in the boulder lake and then ride your
bicycle I [ __ ] I like all that [ __ ]
but guess what guys the last 20 or 25
years I just don't trust society in the
streets that's it I don't trust the
people here and now more than ever that
people are texting now I ain't even know
how to feel about my daughter on a
bicycle because just because you think
the guys watching you're on a side
street there you worse oh they're not
watching you they're texting now
watching it also my bicycle days are
over you want me to get a bite swear
I've got a bicycle but I'm spinning
around the park eighty times I'll do
that all day yeah but that's not what a
bicycle is for now a bicycle is to
[ __ ] go on Explorer and go for a
three to four mile into a park and look
around and get off and drink some water
and stretch your legs and you know but
on the street of bicycle these guys like
tyree used to work with a guy that would
ride his bike for North Hollywood all
the way downtown oh wow and back and
then get on the train to like Chatsworth
Oh Hollywood there's like a train
somewhere don't quote me on this I'm
crazy that takes balls no that takes
[ __ ] balls are bad on out there I
would not be in that [ __ ] 101 dear can
you ride a by someone no wow wow so it's
all sides all side I've never seen a
prize I'm on the 101 but I don't want to
say something that yeah I'm wrong here
you know people do it I see people
walking and riding occasionally but you
can't do that well patrol rolls up on ya
didn't Nick Youssef ride a bike a lot
earlier I used to ride a bike lock
yeah it's uh I raced BMX that was that
was one of the funnest times in my life
just back in my home place came close to
BMX I didn't that she was gonna get into
it it was gonna like my motorcycle
career I was already on a motorcycle so
I don't want to go backwards it seemed
like I was going backwards but I had
friends that were they would go up in
the air and spin their
[ __ ] front I like that it looked like
a lot of [ __ ] fun man
couple weeks ago you know my daughter
has little girlfriends at schools and
it's really hard for you to connect like
the two kids to connect them for their
parents to connect yeah oh that's got to
be weird that's weird
and luckily enough I've connected with
three or four parents ton of cool words
a writer for a drama the other guy's an
actor was done the podcast I got another
guy who he's a video game designer and
his wife's like a [ __ ] world leading
chemists like the man I like a doctorate
chemistry
she can make cocaine I mean I've got a
girl there and shake haha from Jersey
chef very cool and one night we figured
listen one we all get together and let
the wives hang out with the kids hang
out Wong uh and we ended up watching
like something for a little while then
we're like you guys were at my house
I know you know I have an office why
don't we come over to the office and I
came over here with them I think Lee was
doing comedy a Riverside that night or
not I would've invited Lee and it was
two of them and me and I put on you know
I was just putting on random [ __ ] you
know and I put on Pink Floyd first and
we're basically talking about kids and
and acting in this video thing but I
threw on the first Aerosmith and that's
white to it result he goes let's stop
this conversation you know so what is it
that you have on there like Oh Aerosmith
them then he goes jesus [ __ ] christ
you know I bought Aerosmith in 99 with
Jamie's got a gun in here
and I said the us that's not Aerosmith
my show me album cover Jesus Christ
where'd you get this from I go you know
what sadly enough what most people don't
know is that they're one of the few few
bands that really really really
resurrected themselves oh like Jesus
like they did a better job to Jesus
because Jesus left up to 40 days yeah
these [ __ ] stuck around and now
and then they're in their 70s you know
Joe pairi suffering from a bad kind of
time right now he's thinking of touring
the other guy was on Rogue and really
opened up my
eyes but Steven Tyler sad that people
have forgotten you know people bringing
up blackface from a governor in Virginia
don't bring a black face and bring up
[ __ ] if you gonna bring up something
from 1975 bring up toys in the [ __ ]
attic yeah you know yeah bring up the
good stand you know we have a lot of
young listeners on the show you know we
play a lot of music here yeah I've seen
those guys I'm still waiting for them no
material to come out well the young guys
I recall the next the next Led Zeppelin
yeah what's okay credit man fleeing
great man but coming back to me when you
do five hours yeah come back to me after
Physical Graffiti okay and then talk to
me that's the problem
people do three songs and we jump up and
down I'm not taking nothing away from
granilith like that what I'm trying to
do is establish our story that we're
trying to tell to let people know that
the first six Aerosmith albums five
because you like night in the ruts
I don't yeah I like parts of it and then
today I found that why because half of
this is Tyler yeah the other half is
Crespo
yeah Jimmy kraspo Tyler quit in the
middle of the chair Perry Joe Perry quit
yeah sorry we're both two Aerosmith guys
yeah describe to them what Aerosmith was
in the 70s era I saw Aris more the first
time you saw I rose 1978 and it was at
one of those Dan to grains with Ted I
thought about that right so it's the
same time I saw I have a photo that I
put on my Instagram about two months ago
that I found online it's probably one of
the greatest rock phone as I've ever
seen it's just Joe Perry he's got that
gray streak leather pants he's playing
that red BC rich and he's facing the
drummer so you just see the crowd behind
him they were it was called monsters of
rock and they were just a massive
massive rock machine like everybody
knows like the five tunes and it's not
even about that it's about the deep
tracks you know like two
movin all that one another one I love
rats in the cellar nobody's walking
knowing that nobody knows about them oh
just all these deep tracks are the ones
that blow my mind that you just go like
listen to this son and they sound so
original so only band right now with the
all original members still that's crazy
out there but those albums are massive
mass and when you listen especially like
you know when you get into rocks get get
your wings those tunes on there are just
insane and the two guitar players it's
it's phenomenal it's it's weird for me
because I grew up around them and they
weren't my number one yeah my number one
of course it was a fight between Sabbath
and Led Zeppelin and you know then you
had everything else stood on line
whether it was Skynyrd yeah
Judas Priest was a close second you know
I loved priests crowing up I loved skin
and I loved so many different bands but
when the first Aerosmith
I'm not gonna lie they body and tell you
the first thing I ever heard about
Aerosmith was people having an argument
me being a geek basketball player
starting to smoke pot and being at the
courts one day and hearing an argument
between older kids about how Aerosmith
was done you never gonna hear from them
again they're on heroin the rumors out
you know I'm me going who gives a [ __ ]
about everything we gonna let Zeppelin
don't [ __ ] run and [ __ ] yeah you know
but then going to somebody's house and
listening to rocks like getting high and
usually I have a date with another place
I don't remember where I was when I was
getting high and going who is that thing
on Aerosmith rocks the next day I got up
and I walked up to the [ __ ] music
store and I bought Aerosmith rocks and I
put it on and I was completely blown
away and I did something I very rarely
did in those days I put on the second
album I was very naive very if I didn't
hear the song
I would put a lot and when I heard that
second side and I didn't know what drugs
were that I knew what marijuana was but
when I would listen to that I knew it
was Harold like I just knew it was
Harold yeah these guys are into pills or
heroin something's not [ __ ] right
here this is too good
yeah and that was it that was my
Aerosmith thing I was consumed by
Zeppelin and Sabbath and and then I had
a friend that turned me on to get your
wings and I was blown away after that I
get your wings destroyed me like that
cut even on train kept a-rollin I know
Joey but it's a remake I know I know
they stole it from some blues people but
how they did it
yeah it's studio and then it turned into
live you know it was just so I didn't
know I didn't know the order you know I
have to get your wings it was when I
truly got it and when I did what anybody
else did I think I bought toys in the
Attic now that's the first one I got
that was a good out but it wasn't rocks
to me and it was definitely get your
wings
then I bought draw the line which I like
that's kings and queens and I love Kings
and I love that song I love Kings and
Queens
oh yeah the guitar solo on kings and
queens and now I'm full-fledged
Aerosmith I hop the first one with dream
on
I'm full-fledged Aerosmith and my
problem was four years it's not that
I've been lying it's a liability
choosing the words not the right words
I went expected I went expecting a
studio album when I saw him open up for
Ted Wright and it was the studio album
is them very loose so I didn't enjoy it
and we left after the half a tenth we
started walking out because we had a
walk home and we had a walk home on the
metal lanes but we could still hear a 10
I'm route 3 hey let me walk home you can
still hear [ __ ] Ted from the stadium
uh-huh
and then after that I just bought by in
the ruts and then they broke up yeah and
it was shortly after that one
became a real like it was too late
already right those days will end this
time I had friends that had seen
hairless men to open up for sabit in 76
like people had all these Aerosmith
stories and I had missed them and then
they came and they played from the
Meadowlands so think of being at the LA
forum on one year selling out people
drooling all over you
and then three years later being at
what's the worst rock club in Hollywood
oh yeah just being it like I would say
you know like actually over in the
valley FM station that was the old yeah
that's what they were the soap factory
yeah Richfield Park New Jersey which at
least had the dignity in play New York
City which they probably didn't I just
wasn't right to it and I went there and
there were a [ __ ] heroin mess and
that was that without Joe Perry cuz I
was that was what I joked I saw that
same thing they played the Sacramento
State Fair oh they were paving and that
was the song on that tour was lightning
strikes yeah that was the video that was
a video the video haha yeah they were he
was so [ __ ] up on that tour he just
stood up there my old face it was crazy
out loud and he was it was lauded by him
somebody throw a joint to him and him
lighten it and then flicking it back at
the audience
and there was a problem then there was a
fight he got punched in the face a
couple times and that was the end of the
show and I'm like Aerosmith
it's done yeah and then that's what I
really got in there was 82 83 in
Snowmass Village and I was really
getting into rocks get your wings every
day on Saturdays I'm iguana on women go
draw the line yeah it was a real
Aerosmith guy then I was rich it was too
late it's like I got into two bands when
they were already done the Eagles you
know 19 I got it three Eagles as a kid
you know everybody had a hotel count of
one core
everybody had Hotel California but then
I lost track time moved on I got into
girls some content ease I know laughs
and then when I got into Aspen when I
lived in sand basalt
my roommate had the long run oh great I
had gone from I had missed everything in
between
yeah the Eagles a hotel california or
would in the long run it was too later a
the Eagles and broken up and Here I am
sitting coked up in a [ __ ] my bedroom
with earphones on listening for the
[ __ ] long I love the long run I think
it's so underrated it's one of the
greatest greatest Eagles records that
song uh you know boom boom boom boom oh
yeah oh shoot yeah I got like six or
seven songs oh god what that was my
problem I got into both those bands and
they're done couldn't go see him live
and I don't know you know what you're
into right now I know what you people
listen to do me a favor next time you're
gonna take a flight or the usual long
car ride skip a podcast either put on
get your wings start off with that you
could get your wings you could start off
with any of the first six and well don't
tell Dean dumb haha he likes that at the
rut and there's only one song I like
from man the rats the remake of the
Shirelles oh yeah walking in the sand oh
that's great one excellent song I like
on that out I like played in a couple
weeks ago people were bored me [ __ ] you
booing you really wait there's two
albums that you play from that for some
reason my friends on Twitter don't like
oh that's hilarious
my place of technical ecstasy yeah they
always have so this one guy has me with
that line from Fight Club yeah first
rule of black no technical exercise way
that I loved it where's [ __ ] it's
weirdest [ __ ] what likes and then
what they I put in that yeah made the
ruts yeah walking in this is somebody
hit me with that rule number two this
out does not exist
[ __ ] I'm like ah there's a Dean Dean
keeps I listen to it again because you
told me yeah yeah listen to it and I
listen to it again and there's it's got
its but it's not that
and done with dad so now they disappear
yeah I moved to [ __ ] Aspen Colorado
I'm living in the hotel and I'm watching
that TV and not need a black button but
the white girl with the short blonde
hair
oh yeah I came one day I'm stoned I'm
watching MTV and she comes on and says
you know cuz at MTV in the 80s they
would give you that they would give you
him TV news then they would give you a
tidbits at the top of the yeah I love
that I love that that kept you away no
Aziz may gonna come back last night
in fact that day was the 40th
anniversary he bit the head off the head
it was the 40th the something I heard it
somewhere that's crazy and she came on
and said rumors were wild
my only circling and they showed a high
school in Boston it could have been a
cat for school I don't know what it was
but they showed I will submit rehearsing
in the auditorium oh wow
my Carol Smith is making a comeback holy
[ __ ] and then they put on done with
mirrors yeah Ted Templeman produced that
guy they did all the Van Halen's I got
that and it was god-awful I loved it it
just was not what I was used to
I went to see the Joe Perry project oh
yeah Corbin singing yeah and Hart was
opening up for them who was also going
on tour now hearts yeah [ __ ] that we'll
get some of that milkshakes so great
yeah the chubby would say that's it I'm
going on neutral systems to 12 week
I'm putting the girl and I'm going up
then I'm singing for an hour I'm going
that if John could do it I can do it I'm
going to that I had Nancy on the podcast
the other sister the guitar player the
blonde yeah and she broke the news on my
podcast and it went wild people like
they're getting back together
that's her Don Dean Delray's let there
be taught everywhere I was like you know
this is a score getting this this news I
couldn't believe it
so yeah I'll go to that but yeah so then
they announced the done with mirrors
record and I didn't like that
yeah then out of nowhere you know by
this time guys at 85-86
I'm beat until the drum I'm beating to a
different drummer you know saying I
think I had music yeah I always had
music and
my house yeah throw all the moves you
just lose albums and cassettes and
there's somebody else's albums or
something like that so I had lost my way
with Aerosmith and I think I was into
you too oh that's killer
Joshua Tree a great record and the
Bingham was Def Leppard hysteria nine
seven massive Madison hassle drugs and
then somewhere before that was and they
did walk this way Run DMC yep and
[ __ ] everything change them they they
came back bigger than what they were in
the 70s and you look it back at it and
you really can't believe it a lot of
people don't know they think it all
started with Jamie got a gun and
Armageddon and all that dude looks like
a lady and I'm not taking nothing away
from that time period of that I just
like the earlier yeah five up six cuz
need though is it yeah I like the
earliest six out was just because I
don't know I'm a stoic type of guy I
remember what they meant to me at that
time they were just dirty they're dirty
I ever Smith is a lot like Def Leppard
where you and I love Def Leppard before
even anybody they know I'm from from
hysteria on but we know him from on
through the night and high and dry and
and and pyromania this morning I opened
up the week with the first out now rock
brigade oh yeah watch out for the rock
but yeah I don't help end up with you
know when you when you're a fan of a
band you're a fan I'm a [ __ ] back
Tohno you're a fan because you buy all
their work you look at all their work
you compare all their work on your own
you'd have to have a panel call your
best friend you just go on with this
album they let the bass go a little more
never this out of the lyric see we're a
little boy you know I listened to a lot
of deal with Sabbath I'm like who wrote
all those [ __ ] song love that [ __ ]
you know the writing is very important
to me I like you know that's why I get
god I'm still 50 something years old
totally and I still you know they close
that [ __ ] record shoppin
that's what he said that's crazy that
people don't know Burbank
like you you hear about all these cities
in the country Burbank has a no rent no
rent no rent or control
oh no rent control oh no wonder so high
I was doing voiceovers like I've been
doing voiceovers not not booking them
people you want a lot of auditions for
voiceovers you have to put it on mp3 and
send it in I just did one from Buffalo
Wild Wings for the [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] March Madness I hope I get it
oh I don't get none of those things that
they send me up but I was going to a
lady you go over there to a pass Avenue
yep and she's had that office for 18
years and you go in there you pay her
twenty bucks and she puts your voiceover
nice packages of free sent it to the
agent sends it to the casting director
whatever you need she'll do it for you
I've been using it all along it's worth
it and when they should just call me out
of the moment she goes I'm not gonna be
here no more she goes they double the
rent on me for this spot I know what are
you talking about you know they double
the [ __ ] rent on me so she moved to
st. Petersburg Florida she still says
she's doing auditions but no [ __ ] he
sends the auditions long-distance and
she knows if I booked something I still
got a good friend and Van Nuys some she
said they like to stay with but it
wasn't worth it for me no more and then
my wife when she went for them that
baby's birthday cake she walked in and
she said your record shop is closed
that's sax man and then something else
closed in Burbank
something else in it all strep they had
a whole big article about it okay they
did have your article about yeah like
everybody the reason went everywhere
there and it's [ __ ] Burbank is out of
control
it's crazy you could tell they're gonna
not care like you could tell this area
here
oh yeah daddy's up on Lancashire after
the motorcycle place you in the motor
second place it's gone the motors gone
it's all gonna get torn down they're
gonna do it but Burbank closed that
record studio but I saw that new one in
Hollywood that's great Anna and you now
all Bieber's clothes and also know that
clothes and they're gonna move they
heard they found a new building
waiting to hear right right around the
corner or something we're waiting
waiting for the announcement but they're
not closing is moving because they sold
that building and the guys gonna do
something there I like that place
because again I'm very I like amoeba
yeah Michael me if I like I'm a because
anything I go and tell people looking
for it's there I love it you can get
lost in there you get lost in there but
you also get going in and drop my
thousand dollars oh oh it's Birds out
knowing they tell they heavy they have
to hit you have yeah and I don't mind
getting hit heavy for something but
every time I one time I did get it from
endless deal or me but I saw the same
I'm on eBay for a yardstick yeah and I'm
like before I buy it for yardstick when
they see more me McConnell me buy it for
10bux so I'm not here badmouth little
[ __ ] BMO's come through for me a lot yeah
but sometimes you got old me but it's 50
hours for from now I know I paid $7.99
for this [ __ ] around 20,000 years ago
wise I tried to buy him on the road like
with I'm out with Marin we hit up some
record store in in small cities where
you know they think $15 is a lot and
you're like these are 15 they go yeah
sorry it's kind of steep you're like
cool let me get all of these you know
because they're still in in times of low
low prices and every time I go to
Hollywood I always send myself today as
a dad got a little Bieber until you go
over there and they got a 9 car waitlist
if I hang in there is no parking around
the [ __ ] corner you Circle it Circle
it circle it and circle it and then you
finally go [ __ ] this and you just shoot
up going and come home that's all I
could think of yeah every time I go to
Hollywood I always go today's the day
yeah yeah I'm going to old me BA go up
Cole whatever that Street is yeah I'll
sing you like really there's a four cars
waiting to get in that means 20 minutes
before I fine and sometimes it's quick
sometimes it is and sometimes you go in
and you have the parking spot right next
to the [ __ ] stairs oh I love
I love that you run up at this houses
everywhere yeah throw down hands and
[ __ ] photos and you go in there but
like I said like you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna go to date night to
Friday's yeah and take my wife that
[ __ ] good old be but no crazy cuz
have been it's great and that's the best
time to call you in Friday nights
I know that is the right things is the
best time we go it's empty
nobody bothers you you zip right in
there you could spend an hour I love
looking at my wife and go and see you
later here's my trick good I park in the
ArcLight parking lot across the street
and you get the ticket and then I just
have them have them valid at $3 and then
I can be in a me but for hours hours
just no problem and not have to worry
about an old label park alone you don't
have to pay no you're not to pay but if
it's full I don't want a park on the
street like miles away trying to find
something and court you know from that
area government alright say there's some
homeless down there it's it's it's just
crowd yeah
a bit too [ __ ] much it's just a bit
but that area no no no no guys yeah I
lived around the block there for 10
years you have a bunch Raider from two
thousand or two thousand [ __ ] nine I
was a block from there I used to walk to
all be but as fat as I was I can walk
through amoeba
no come on walked over me but no problem
I would walk all around the [ __ ]
neighborhood stop at the jack-in-the-box
mmm I had a God for that jack-in-the-box
and a long [ __ ] time yeah last
someone went that I Jacqueline box I had
to be when I first want to date my wife
mm yeah I mean like when I was young it
was just so wacky
it was like when I was growing up I
wasn't allowed to eat that [ __ ]
jack-in-the-box was up in the Bronx yeah
oh look like it was scary
jack-in-the-box in the fish place yeah I
was a fish place Long John Silver
no there was one before that in the East
Coast it was a chain on the East Coast
they were nasty yeah he would get sick
every time anything my mom didn't let me
do you know I was a lot to eat fast food
growing up oh I didn't eat any that
either
well sis after baseball game I went to
Miami I would eat fast food around my
cousins yeah but if I was home around my
mother I wasn't allowed to eat fast food
head cell phone there's nothing better
than a [ __ ] Big Mac Oh old school Oh
max I don't like double burgers darling
I can't eat double patties it's not much
yeah well I think my daughter's
MacDonnell's not control myself I don't
need no fries but I would like too many
they have a many not whopper
that's disgusting forgetting is done
then we get Burger King what time we
threw out the window I think there was
someone else yeah we start out the
[ __ ] window
it was so [ __ ] bad Burger King used
to be delicious
all Burger King tasted great flavor yeah
the [ __ ] those chicken sandwiches
were the first it was damn and Wendy's
now I love the square Wendy's first came
up no no
when wendy's first came up I was a
[ __ ] chicken cutlet type of
[ __ ] Wendy's daughter yeah I
was never really a [ __ ] burger guy at
Wendy's and that chili you're eating
somebody's lamp girl somewhere going me
sue me sue oh I don't know what you'd
call a melon me sue I don't [ __ ] it then
yeah yeah that's just too crazy I went
to square burger big time I love but
when I moved here I struggled on sunset
when I lived with Josh wolf
oh that $0.99 cheeseburger and the
ninety cents a cup of chili
bastok two for three dollars you need
when you couldn't afford hallways walk
you always had [ __ ] that 99-cent
cheeseburger
now the junior cheeseburger for 99 cents
and they give you advance since 99 cents
cup of chili I would go in there like
there was Morton's I would mine bucks
like it was once yeah it would be there
slow and [ __ ] get like extra crackers to
dope up the chili that you really get
full yeah people have no idea what
suffering is when you go into a chili
and it's Morton's ah like I mean that
should happen but somebody telling me
[ __ ] salad what's and I almost took
my glove up smack them in the face
Joey needs the Betty salads yeah I used
to live on those two burgers for a
dollar from where I am p.m. across the
street from the whiskey the grossest
[ __ ] ever but it was two for a dollar
burgers are good too yeah and they all
right and then when the guy wasn't
looking I'd go over to the nacho cheese
and blast it onto the burger and wrap it
back up start up nacho cheese on the
burger two for a dollar and then buy a
pack of cigarettes
I'm a being broke his debt flying out of
LAX and they have that ham p.m. on the
corner of century yeah
and I would go and then I'd see those
two cheeseburgers and I'd be as happy as
[ __ ] but those are the kind of food they
need let's say a prayer when you take
the last bite time cuz you don't know
where you're gonna end up it's like
coming to this office yeah you don't
know what you're gonna eat a touch by
mistake you might be doing heroin
ketamine Jeremy you know what you do to
this [ __ ] office that scares me about
those is like getting diarrhea
immediately soon as you get on the plane
well you know you what you build up a
tolerance when you're a starving comic
yeah you build up a Towers you do you do
towers I remember it always had a pickle
I would just immediately just fling the
pickle like a coin on it I'll keep it on
a river no that pill that pickles
disgust across it was old when it got
that yeah it's like yeah it's like the
pickles from White Castle
you gotta think twice before you bite
into all these see you later to that
pickle immediately it would just be
flying down sunset no idea those three
or four years that you really you're
eating just to exist as a convenient
that's it you're reading at the club
which is horrible
oh and when they give you extra food
your dick would get on you you were
broke yeah flat broke
when you did it in proud we felt like
you're eating like a king
oh my god what about the first time you
was a comedy magic club they gave me the
salmon Oh was to go oh one to go want to
go yeah I given you $2,000 in the old
days that's crazy him for having the old
days I got that [ __ ] they were
offering one to go
you bet your ass I took whatever the
[ __ ] they were giving I don't kitchen
take the onion ring seasoned fries yeah
artichoke dip we just learned to eat
that [ __ ] because that was hot that's a
little better you don't know when you're
eating no yeah I still remember being in
Michigan man living off those Subway
sandwiches as bad mouth as I bad mouth
subway yeah those veggie and cheese
sandwiches head would they [ __ ] I
thank them I thank them that should be
there their motto subway we get you
through it you're dirt-poor we get you
we tweak we supply the nutrition to get
your dreams you know ice it's just
really crazy to think about the [ __ ] you
eat on the road like I never went rogue
[Laughter]
I never broke down it was worse than
like dunkey brother but huh everything I
ate I ate with a smile a sort of prayer
while I was easy if some we shaved
better than others yeah like some weeks
you ate better than others you know you
and I going to Houston Texas March 7th
through the [ __ ] battle oh you know
April hey Pat hey March 7 8 9 March
seventh eighth ninth
you know I used to go to Houston and it
was just an eating fest yeah like I know
I was going to use the snort coke and he
had both of my value just as much Connie
was the third on the list yeah it was
the [ __ ] food you know yeah it's but
now I would need half that should I used
to eat me yeah now it's all about ease
yeah clean good stuff
what's amazing I don't try to eat meat
at night anymore like the fifties of you
know yesterday I don't know if you guys
know what happened yesterday we're
trying to do a podcast here way and I
ate some edibles and for the second time
in the [ __ ] Hannah in the podcast
career I fell asleep while I was talking
to Steve Simone oh man
Apple was like last May I gave up on the
edibles like I started going away from
edibles like maybe last April altogether
and then I dropped off the map you were
always on those stars yeah and you
quitting they're [ __ ] your stomach or
something did something was not right so
I had to determine what what the cause
was so I had to make a list of
elimination right right and it came up
with milk it was milk and dairy that was
really killing me what sorrell cheese
huh we're really killing me and
something was just wrong my stomach so I
just gave it all up and after I gave it
up I realize how toxic we were eating
those those edibles to a toxic you feel
it's like when you call the dentist he
gives you a prescription of door closed
the first two are great the second two
are great but after four days them what
you weaned off you're gonna go Jesus
Christ
my body's working overtime yeah to get
me back normal that's how bad they are
for your body you have to work out what
you know that [ __ ] clings on to your fat
like when I used to be a valium celled
I used to look yeah I used to love
selling valium I had this connection in
long buck but half when you take a 10
milligram to have value your body only
uses five the other five gets stuck to
your fat oh that's insane
you didn't know that but no cuz I always
knew you had to take a tank as the fives
were weak weak because there's only two
and a half that stick the effect never
knew that we take a 10 you buy the only
uses 50% kill that's why the next day
when you get high at 4 in the afternoon
you [ __ ] not out during the news guys
you're releasing that your body releases
it it's a time release if you eat ten of
those volumes every night they just
stock up in your system you don't sweat
to have a drink a lot of [ __ ] water
you'll feel the toxicity now you stopped
daughter and that's how I felt when I
got off the edibles in April or May
March whatever it was two months later
I'm like that was a little something
extra those [ __ ] things yeah you
start feeling way better
it just wasn't THC yeah well maybe it
was THC maybe I'm wrong yeah but I
cleaned them up and every day it's like
what people say to you when you're an
addict just
you're not doing that drug doesn't mean
that your addiction has grown you can be
clean for 10 years from coke and all you
need is that one line to get you going
and you're right back where you were
that's what's going on with the country
would have just reset that you just
reset then you die because ever do to
you the same amount yeah then you would
do it when you quit well let me tell you
something bro being lien you're the
witness you you were here when we get a
leave from outer space yeah you were
here many a times we [ __ ] will [ __ ]
up the [ __ ] those edibles that we get
now little capsules what's family yeah
there are less the what is this absolute
extracts that we got from Sam showed me
access ABX those things are no joke I
will tell you there's no [ __ ] joke
with those two hundred milligrams and
your night-night 300 yeah are you done
like shits moving you can't stop eating
I'm just a hundred I must a steak
sandwich system and every sandwich I
kept saying there's gonna be the last
one oh [ __ ] [ __ ] up I can't do that no
more paranoid eat at night these have to
be for like cancer patients that don't
have a Santa but with h2o an oxygen
atoms [ __ ] yeah because go right into
your system dawg I felt it halfway
during the podcast yesterday we commit
we can't release that podcast yeah oh we
had a guest to some poets and we were
sitting around here for a while waiting
not for Steve someone else but yeah
those and the thing about those is is
animals take a while to kick in some
time I ate that 30 minutes before I got
in when I walked in the door I said to
myself how [ __ ] hungry about oh and
my wife I just made a tremendous lunch
for me and the door I go how can I be
hungry we got so hungry
yeah that we paid 60 bucks for three
sandwiches
oh they had of the liberal before the
podcast we got by 2:30 we had to order
sandwiches and how fast they go down
there was a little sausage one and Lee
kept looking at it like
I know was over that in the Steven
Kendall's gonna eat it and finally we
just we ate those sandwiches what I said
Simone was not hot yeah it was just me
and Lee and then I popped another like
only let's do another one and that was
it it was night night after that I was
never to see that because I never seen
you out like that myself right here yeah
telling the story and just waking up and
Lee and some mom going oh my god uh and
then I left here I went home and I was
watching cartoons at the baby I'm here
15 minutes you would poke me ain't no
daddy I was [ __ ] up
oh she was in the tub I went back there
talked well I don't know what she said
yeah and then I will ask for the couch
and I told you guys that I was I was
hungry last night but I'm like this is
not happy but she just went grocery
shopping so I know there's baloney in
there
Bologna's I'm wearing that [ __ ]
because she makes it for the kids for
sandwich at school yeah so she hides it
because I'll get up I'll kind of handle
lettuce and I'll stop making Bologna and
cheese sandwiches with lettuce until the
cows come home a little mustard I told
you I have no reason to lie to anybody
yeah two three weeks ago one night the
first thing I got those was a Tuesday
and I got on stage
I got off stage playing oh how bad could
they be I pop one huh and when I got out
stayed in the original I was already
feeling the tinglies by the time I got
over Laurel Canyon
I could eat a [ __ ] mule Oh about
going to you I control myself no I'm not
going to young girls told me somebody
told me that you've got a great jalapeno
croissant oh you put Turkey on this and
they say ah and I went home and I sat
there bro I just started going off first
it was two or three bananas ah then it
was a red apple then I started it with
the cashews Oh what the cashews and I'm
hungry I'm done after that it's worry
man for himself so I made one bologna
sandwich of American cheese and lettuce
drank Coke Zero five I drank and I ain't
another sandwich
you got stay off I think I really ate
four sandwich before sandwiches and the
thing is it and it doesn't even seem
you're eating a sandwich yeah like it
seems like if you have like one two
bites and then they're gone it was crazy
it really is this is if you really want
to get I buy those things I think the
people that these are designed for
people that get chemotherapy because
they're not that is chemotherapy your
body's rather all right you the last
time because you're not hungry and this
will make you crazy I'm telling you that
last night there was a point where I
looked at my body that account and I
look like one of those fat guys my
600-pound Shamu I was adding my two legs
on two different footrest couch and I
was giving myself till ten o'clock ten
o'clock I gotta stay up till 10:00
and I kept saying I'm gonna make a
protein shake and find that rule there's
one ham ham gonna make a protein shake
before I go to bed because it's better
to drink a protein shake before you go
to bed see rebuild your muscles I was
scared to take the nine steps I went
after the bedroom of my wife was reading
a Kindle
yeah those that's it I don't even answer
I just took off my shirt took off my
sweats I usually put pajama bottoms on
me a dese ah and she was talking to me
bro I cuddled up I put that sleep apnea
mask on with that hose sticking out
I put the fan on ten usually it's not
four it wasn't blowing wigs off his [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hit it hard
I didn't call nobody I didn't talk I
didn't plug my phone in before I went to
bed that's how [ __ ] high was you're a
[ __ ] pro imagine rookies on that Oh
imagine I pass it good the Heat's on
here because her wintry yeah he left it
like five ish he called me a couple
times and I I think about six and you
wake up but you don't know you're asleep
so you kind of wake up
startled a little bit and I was sure was
eight o'clock it was 10 p.m. [ __ ] I woke
up here a week ago at 7:00 a.m. oh man I
I got up like where's the podcast up I
go I don't even want to know
oh yeah cuz I was just as highway we
have four weird weed war room that night
I call them at 9:00 he goes you're not
gonna believe it I and I left him here
to 8:30 yeah yeah at night oh and he
said he woke up at 6:30 in the morning
dun da dines are [ __ ] done
the coma done the lights are all like
everything's on the books that's it yeah
let's write the time down down with
edibles what's the date today February
11th February 11th you know for the
animal six hours bro this morning I woke
up Ross there's two left in here that
don't cuz what could be it won't believe
that's the good yet by yellowbrickroad
yeah yeah at least fathers coming so
we're gonna give him to it ah [ __ ] he's
put him on the couch now rub his little
head Tony wakes up one foot later this
is what the [ __ ] happened I don't move
over vacation in California that's a
shame they're [ __ ] insane so yeah man
we'll go on to Houston we're also going
to Minneapolis in the 19th I can't wait
and we're going to uh no walk low
walking over 28 for the Pasadena I'm
black I'm happy that you had a chance to
come on I wish people really listen to
all these Aerosmith's out I wish we
convince some young people to [ __ ]
put the first five six ABS on yeah the
[ __ ] first album is tremendous it's
filthy dirty rusty you know it's got the
original dream ah yeah originally the
dream of masterpiece and obviously
anyone can listen to it but just like
one of the first times I ever went to
your house joy was you showing me
Aerosmith and just giving me like like
can you tell cuz we have a lot of people
in Boston like you need tell the people
in Boston like why if they haven't
listen Aerosmith like what Aerosmith
meant to Boston at that time because
like that you just think about it you
think about 1973 to 76 what was going on
the Red Sox were on top of that [ __ ]
game the Celtics won on top of that game
the Patriots yeah they went to the Super
Bowl without a drink ticket but they
lost yeah I don't know what the hockey
team was doing the Boston Moon's
but it was a tough setting yeah I didn't
I had never gotten uh I'm not gonna tell
you I bet I've never been to Boston well
I
just meaning just from how Dave Cowens
played the game just how the coaches I
knew it was a sports city oh yeah
totally
think about this in 1976 is 75 the Red
Sox went to the World Series against the
Cincinnati Reds and Boston was still
playing locally around you know whatever
I mean there will be huge
after that the album that made him was
draw the line yeah
no yeah the for town was the one that
put him internationally and they really
we got we got Toys in the Attic had had
the hit on it Walk This Way
right so Toys in the Attic was the
second the third one that was a big big
that was a big that's the one that can
hope it wasn't wrong yeah it was toys of
the Attic was that big 10 inch yep and
Walk This Way and a watch of [ __ ] so you
know think about Boston at that time
think about there's no internet think
about there's really no 200 channels
it's just you the Celtics
the Red Sox the Bruins or the [ __ ]
New England Patriots yes is banned out
of Boston that's on the national level
with Led Zeppelin and you know so think
about how hard it was to creep out a
boss in those days it wasn't like you
know yeah it was tough there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on oh you want me to see
long-haired people yeah I know the boss
the Celtics and sit there with gentlemen
with military crew ton you know john
havelcheck
was the staple of Boston then you mercy
will hand job John have a checklist like
a [ __ ] quiet boy yeah his hairs done
on this side he's number 17
you know Boston had this reputation he
is these dirty guys turn supposedly they
want heroin and that's why by the way
not to throw anybody off recommended
reading if you're gonna listen to these
Aerosmith town and you do your homework
assignment wrap it up take care yourself
and buy the book walk this way that's
the book I think you came on 98 that's
crazy
by the book walked this way Bobby don't
send it to me I got it at the house
you know sent me any book we talked
about how many guys like the house
bobbling guitars our man in Chicago but
Walk This Way is a tremendous book and
because it's not the band's story from
the singer or from the manager it's from
all five of them and you could see how
people's perspectives is that's why I
liked about it that someday me you ran
in Bozzio and Lee I'll tell the story
about what we did for Lee and out of
space yeah and you're gonna say we
didn't have what Raina's ever say we did
ecstasy I'm gonna say we did clay mm and
Lee's gonna say I don't know what I did
it was a lot everybody's still good acid
I did this I did that you know was
saying so it's early story and I learned
a lot I learned about the perspective of
their band and it also taught me about
what a bands perspective is I never
looked at it through those eyes yeah you
know with stand-up comics we worry about
ourselves I gotta worry about Lee not
doing too much heroin ODS the first
losing one of your guys it's like yeah
these guys kept it together
I mean towards the end they didn't talk
to each other to see that interesting
dynamic that they still got to put out
an album called rocks and it was
tremendous and at the time they were not
talking to one another don't think Tyler
that's silver sorry they were just
crossing the night and day one guy was
singing at night and one guy was lambs
tracks that they thought and I think it
ended because Perry's wife threw a drink
somebody else's wife after a show I
forget the story but it was definitely
yeah it was definitely that kind of [ __ ]
disrespect my wife or whatever one of
them every laughs who started the
project whatnot they're getting a star
this week
are they on Hollywood Boulevard what day
I don't know what day it is can you look
that up way they're getting a star and
then they're gonna kick off their
residency in Vegas and I'm gonna go to
that if you're gonna be playing in Vegas
I guess all year on and off a residency
and they played last night somewhere in
Hollywood for like a charity and they
opened with back in the saddle I watched
it online
did they really
look they look great she says sounded
great I saw him three years ago at the
Staples they were mind-boggling Thursday
Thursday they're getting their star and
they're getting it right in front of MIT
which is Musicians Institute where all
the people learn to play guitar drums
and all that right there on Hollywood
Boulevard by the Ripley's Believe It or
Not okay yeah which is does that leave
I'm done damn I'm in San Jose
[ __ ] what shows early shows
already sold out The Late Show there's
maybe 50 tickets left so do what you
need to do you know I'd love to see I
can't wait thing up to San Jose go to
original Jose and do my thing we're
still hooked up for March to go see the
michael Shank their experiment yeah
we're going it whiskey yep three nights
that three nights yeah I like to do one
night with yeah yeah see that we're
going Joey's going to see Michael
Schenker and I'm happy you're back man I
love LA are you back for a long time
Betty okay you said a long time yeah
long time happy about him you will
definitely be back for the we're gonna
do a podcast to commemorate the 40 year
hey there truly it's really weird when I
think about hi with Al I'm gonna wrap it
up with this but it's really weird that
they I went how got me started
yep how would how was my intro that was
it August 4th 1979 it's so weird I went
to see the longest 4th 1979 and I
checked to see when the album came out
you know when the album came out a week
after before July 27th oh there you go
ticking back there oh I was gonna make a
mistake on the podcast oh yeah I
remember getting fired up I only
listened cut it out gonna be three days
before I went yeah my favorite song was
walk all over you from Mary I would how
was that I wish somebody I wish we
wouldn't we use cameras in those days I
wish somebody would have taped it from
us leaving the party to us taking the
bus to walk to the garden just early and
the garden to see an Angus run around to
seeing Ted Nugent go up the weekend
warriors to us walking home it was just
a tremendous experience but we'll talk
about that July I can't wait do the
party
am i way too [ __ ] how [ __ ] I want
to thank my main man Dean Delray it's
been a while I want to thank the
[ __ ] I want to thank the
[ __ ] fire department for chiming in
they're giving you a little beep the
beep but most importantly I want to
thank squarespace.com let me ask you
something do you have a cool idea you
want to turn into a website
squarespace.com is the where to go they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online with the ability to
customize the look and feel settings and
products and more with just a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box it's a new way to buy
domains and choose from over 200
extensions you can showcase your work
buh-bah go publish content or sell
products and services of all kinds so
head over to squarespace.com right now
right now squarespace.com
for a free trial it's free what do you
got to lose and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code shirt
si-hu rch to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com enter code Church okay
listen it's time you've been dreaming
about it it's time to get that website
going go to squarespace.com right now
for a free trial when you enter code
church number two let me ask you
something 66% of men of men lose their
hair by the age of 35 I'm losing it
right now and I'm fifty [ __ ] six and
I'm not too happy about it so I might
even give four heads a shot the thing is
when you start to know this hair loss
it's too late it's easier to keep the
hair that you have then to replace to
handle your loss you got it so do you
want a bald spot to pop up do you want
your hairline to recede or do you want
to do so about it go to for him is calm
right now
it's a one-stop shopping for hair loss
skin care and sexual wellness for men
let me tell you something and when I
talk about sexual wellness for men I
talk about the helmet you might have a
little problem on a date you know you
get to that age where you have erectile
dysfunction they'll help you out
you're like Joey how
thanks to science baldness erectile
dysfunction skincare listen we have on
all new world out there hims connects
you with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat your hair loss with
well-known generic equivalents to make
name brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair or help you with your
erectile problem or anything else you
have listen there's no snake oil pills
or gas station counter supplements these
are prescription solutions backed by
science there's no waiting room Norwood
no awkward person that doctor visits
your other guy that you're not working
right save hours and embarrassment in
time by going to for hims calm right now
it's easy you answer a few questions
the doctor will review it and they
prescribe you what you need the products
are shipped directly to your door you
don't have to leave the goddamn house
that's how much I believe in for hims
calm so do me a favor the church family
gets a free trial month of hymns for
five hours right now five hours it's
five hours you spent $5.00 on Dumber
things let's take care of your hair loss
let's take care of your erectile
dysfunction five hours while supplies
last see the website for full details
this would cost you hundreds if you went
to a doctor so do me a favor go to
forums comm slash Joey again that's for
hems comma slash Joey and take care of
this problem and for your supplements
you know me you got to go to Harnett com
they're the masters a disaster whether
it's a shroom tack whether it's a
Mexican chocolate protein powder whether
it's the alpha brain listen they got it
I can't do nothing for you with
kettlebells and the bats but when it
comes to supplements your Uncle Joe is
here go to Holland calm right now I'm
press in charge boom and get 10% off
your order but anyway as usual thank you
very much it's great to see you
congratulations on your success
thank you man you and I going to Houston
can't wait whatever like I said I'll be
in San Jose this ders that's all that's
available everything else is sold out
then the 22nd I'm in Vegas at the
Treasure Island with Kate Quigley and
the 23rd at the Fox Theatre in Tucson
with Kate Quigley Kate Vella is
definitely coming to kidnap e man so
make sure you are there
kick this [ __ ] melee yeah